Donald Trump mentioned the new f-35  fighter jet that is currently in  production for our military and in the  speech he called the new fighter jet  fantastic and I was watching that other  people thought this - I thought  fantastic was kind of an odd way to  describe a military fighter jet but the  makers of the f-35 Lockheed Martin  apparently disagree in fact they've  already released this ad for the f-35  fighter jet check it out it is a  fantastic new f-35 jet fighter fantastic  a success fantastic you heard what the  president said the new f-35 fighter jet  is fantastic fantastic look at it go  this jets got SAS class and it's gonna  protect your acts have a goddamn  cocktail you're safe  f-35 fighter jet Lockheed Martin  [Music]  it's got fat  it's got class and it's gonna protect  your ass right  you